this is news no parent wants to hear
news no parent wants to relay
the father of jordan gatli telling
family and friends his son has died in
the war in ukraine
the 24 year old shot and killed in the
city of severo donetsk
it was something he thought about
carefully said his dad
leaving the british army in march to
join the foreign legion in ukraine
yet the situation in severo donetsk is
intense the russians concentrating much
of their firepower on the city and
ukrainian forces have struggled to hold
on
there are thousands of civilians stuck
in the city and 560 stranded in its
battered chemical plant
in a heartfelt tribute gatley's father
wrote jordan and his team were so proud
of the work they were doing and he often
told me that the missions they were
going on were dangerous but necessary he
loved his job and we are so proud of him
he truly was a hero and will forever be
in our hearts
soldiers in the british army have
praised his professionalism including
his best friend barney who joined up
with gatli on the same day in 2016.
i don't think you'd find a
better soldier than jordan in my books
to be honest with you um
he was um
unique in everything he did
his knowledge of everything was
you know
top tier i'd say he's um
my
best friend is a bit of an
understatement you know we were brothers
and the mayor of severo donetsk
alexander strook also paid his respects
we managed to reach him despite a poor
internet connection
what is your reaction to the death of
this british soldier jordan gatli
[Music]
look my reaction is this sadness and
pity which we have for every soldier
defending our city for ukrainian
soldiers for british soldiers for french
and germans anyone in the foreign legion
they defend our land and they help us
fight back
gatli becomes the second british
volunteer to lose his life in ukraine a
former commando called scott sibley died
in april he was 36
but tens of thousands of foreign
fighters remain
many joining several international
brigades after the russians invaded in
late february jordan gatli's death is
both a tragedy and a reminder of the
risks that foreign nationals take when
they fight for ukraine it's not a
skirmish it's a full-scale war and
officials have been increasingly frank
about ukrainian losses every day 100 or
more soldiers lose their lives and
another 500 suffer injuries
jordan gatli died in the desperate
defense of a region far from home
but his father said he believed in this
cause and his courage has been
recognized and praised
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine